1-1 ce que je cherchais rassure levée
oui tout à fait dix ans que il disait
pourtant porno de créer une cohérence au
niveau de toutes les villes avec
lesquelles le président l'inspiration
jumelage nous avons effectivement
procédé à une première opération de
jumelage avec la ville de houilles
qu'est la ville de naissance de la
famille de victor schoelcher la ville de
fessenheim pardon et maintenant il
s'agit de faire en sorte que nous
puissions avec la ville de hue perpétuer
justement cette tradition à travers une
ville justement au victor schoelcher à
vivre une bonne partie de sa vie et où
l'un est mort également
donc sur cette base là il était
important pour nous de créer les
conditions justement de des changes qui
puisse nous permettre de nous rappeler
ce que fut ce grand homme sont
abolitionnistes victor schoelcher